gold bitcoin or d5 how can investors
hedge against inflation and a note
sent to client strategist at wall street
banking giant jp morgan has suggested
that a one percent portfolio allocation
to bitcoin could serve a hedge against
fluctuations in traditional asset
classes that's jp morgan that's jamie
dimon saying one percent in bitcoin the
decentralized finance defy
sector is a viable alternative by using
stable coins cryptocurrencies with the
price of a control mechanism and
decentralized applications
investors could outpace inflation while
resisting the risk of a spot position to
do this they simply have to find a way
to earn interest on the stable coins
that would be above annual inflation
rates bitcoin's more attractive as a
store of value than other assets chester
commodities as growing demand can
only be met by rising prices and not
traditional production and then this the
last one gold has underperformed this
year
dropping 8.6
against the dollar while the cpi in the
u.s moved up 6.2 inflation gold failed
investors who bet on it while btc
bitcoin is up
92.3 percent year-to-date rewarding
those who believe
in it as a hedge thoughts you hear the
narrative yeah you hear the narrative
yes gold failed you this week so
go with the sit with the bitcoin so we
can track everything that you buy all
right there's 12 trillion dollars with
the gold in the whole world okay so if
if everybody with financial let's say
there's like you know
uh 250 trillion of financial assets in
the world you know okay if one percent
of those tried to go into gold
forget about it it does not exist like
that's the market cap of gold or
something is 12. 12 trillion versus
bitcoin bitcoin is one trillion
so it's 12x bitcoin yeah but look my
point is is that is that if they said
put one percent of your portfolio into
gold in for worldwide
you better have guns because
it doesn't exist like the annual supply
is about 3 000 tons and shrinking okay
there's there's no way like who's going
to give you the gold you know the
government central bank of russia forget
about it like you know all the the elite
families of the world you know
mining in our antarctica and deep sea
mining will begin and all that no no way
i mean it's too it's too expensive you
better have five thousand an ounce to
get the stuff off the bottom of the
ocean like you could forget about it
it's not possible like i'm in the
business i'm telling you that like you
you the the the low value gold to go
after is not there okay and so you read
these pieces and what's the narrative
the narrative is oh you're now worried
about inflation buy crypto that'll
protect you you did nine times because
bitcoin's up ninety percent inflation
they say is six it's really ten okay so
you did nine times better than inflation
this year just buy some bitcoin and boom
you're you're good let me ask you do you
ever have dialogue or debates with
staunch crypto or bitcoin people like a
pomp
versus an eb if you guys were debating
right now and you're like oh this is
what it is he's like no you don't
understand bitcoin yeah i don't think
you guys clash what does that
conversation would be better
have a conversation with kurt from last
week i don't think it's right i don't
think it's like better you know i just i
just don't think it accomplishes the
purpose that the narrative tells you
that it accomplishes so do you not own
crypto out of zero no no i mean it's not
spiteful i mean i'm just like look i you
only need one trick in your in your bag
right i mean like i know how to create
wealth on the royalty business model
like i know how to do that and it's
available to everyone it's not like i
created wealth and then took the company
public at peak valuation i used the
public company to buy the royalties so
you could have bought the stock for 80
cents a share u.s when we started you
know it's like up 9x right now okay and
it's had a terrible year and we used
that to acquire all the royalties we
went to the guy that owned the royalty
we said we'll give you a million of
stock and a million of cash to buy the
royalty now we have two now we have four
now we have 25 now we have 50. now we
have 70. okay so we have like hundreds
of thousands of ounces of gold in the
ground spread all over the world that
someone else is going to dig up and the
actual investor could have done could
have been with us the whole way i bought
the stock in the market like as a
director you can you can see that so i
know how to make money in this zone and
so my thing with crypto is it's like i
don't really need
to go and
have a thumb drive with you know 20
bitcoin on it just to be in it i don't
understand a lot of people that would
disagree with you on that because to me
uh of uh for example like the whole
storage thing i think that's a lot
that's going to be a big argument that
they're going to have palms gonna have
on his side
uh the argument of direct fight of
crypto versus uh gold i think crypto's
gonna win i don't think gold is a direct
fight
against i think gold is a fight against
fiat i think gold is a fight against
that if you ever fight directly with
bitcoin you're going to get your tail
handed to you because their argument is
a better argument and i'm not a crypto
guy or a gold guy i'm simply a business
guy is what i am i'm talking from a very
logical reasonable
side myself so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]